[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
da sind wir wieder mit einem weiteren
wahren Verbrechen ich bin Toni Hayer und
ich bin Mirko Kasimir hallo schön dass
ihr dabei seid uns beschäftigt heute ein
sehr klassisches Motiv für ein
Verbrechen wir hatten es ja jetzt oft
mit Liebe Eifersucht Hass oder Sadismus
zu tun aber heute da geht es um nackte
Gier es war nämlich die Aussicht auf
fette Beute die im Jahr 2017 zu einem
ganz ganz üblen und blutigen Überfall
führte Mirko der Fall wurde als
Doppelmord von Höfen bekannt und für
bild-reporterin Lena Zander ist er eine
der Geschichten die einen noch lange
beschäftigen die Polizei sprach auch
später von einer unfassbaren Brutalität
die in dem Gebiet ich meine man sich das
vorstellen dass es ein beschaulicher Ort
in Bayern wirklich einmalig gewesen ist
die Täter sind wahnsinnig brutal
vorgegangen haben das Opfer mit
Schraubendreher an malträtiert die
Wangen durchstochen und auch beim
Versuch den den Mann den
Übernachtungsgast in den Keller zu
bringen haben sie ihnen die Kellertreppe
runter gestoßen also der Mann war blutig
der Mann war verletzt das sind doch
alles ältere Herrschaften gewesen die
den körperlich sowieso unterliegen
gewesen sind und wenn man sich vorstellt
wie sie da vorgegangen sind dann ist das
schon echt besonders schlimm und
besonders grausam
lena wird in dieser Folge noch mehrmals
zu Wort kommen denn eins ist bei diesem
Fall anders als bei vielen anderen er
hört nicht mit dem Gerichtsurteil auf
nach dem Schuldspruch bleibt die
bildreporterin dran weil sie verstehen
will was im Mörder vorgegangen ist aber
begeben wir uns doch erstmal an den Ort
des Geschehens den Ort an dem das Grauen
in das Leben von Luise pekam ihren Namen
haben wir übrigens geändert Luise P
wohnt in Höfen das ist ein kleiner Teil
des Ortes Königsdorf südlich von München
zwischen Bad Tölz und dem Starnberger
See die Zeitung Welt schreibt zutreffend
grüne Wiesen Kühe der weiß blaue Himmel
kurz um Bayern von seiner schönsten
Seite und doch hat sich hier einen
brutaler doppeltereignet der ganz Bayern
erschütterte
die ältere Dame wohnt hier mit ihrem
schwerkranken Mann als das Paar im Jahr
2016 die polnische Pflegerin Marco
Charta l einstellt Luise P nennt sie der
Einfachheit halber nur Margot sie bleibt
aber nur ein paar Monate bis Louises
Mann schließlich stirbt das
Arbeitsverhältnis endet im Herbst des
selben Jahres vor Gericht wird Luise P
später sagen sie habe schon bei My
goratas Einstellung um gutes Gefühl
gehabt und tatsächlich in den Monaten
beim Ehepaar pay fällt der Pflegerin auf
dass es im Haus viel Geld gibt und sogar
Goldbarren so entsteht eine teuflische
Idee
mein gotta berichtet in Stettin ihrem
Bruder Robert P und ihrem Sohn Michael n
vom Reichtum in Höfen
und sie Hacken zusammen mit einem damals
34 Jahre alten Bekannten namens Jakub g
Spitzname Kuba einen Raub aus konnte die
Frau ahnen wie brutal ein solcher
Überfall schließlich ausfallen würde das
beschäftigt später auch das Gericht denn
marco scharta ist Bruder Robert ist
mehrfach vorbestraft und seit Jahren
drogenabhängig auf den Fotos der Polizei
sieht man ihn später als athletischen
Mann mit kurzgeschorenen Haaren und
einem intensiven fast stechenden Blick
wahrscheinlich stellen sich die drei
Räuber und ihre Komplizen alles ganz
einfach vor hinfahren alte Frau fesseln
und fettbeute machen am 22 Februar 2017
macht sich das Trio auf nach Höfen
schon in den Wochen davor hatten die
Männer das Haus bei Erkundungsfahrten
ausgespielt um für den Raub perfekt
vorbereitet zu sein am Tag des Überfalls
kommen sie bis an die Oberkante
vollgedröhnt am Haus an und das ist
nicht das einzige unheilvolle Vorzeichen
nochmal Lena Zander was sie aber nicht
wussten ist dass die wohlhabende Witwe
deren Mann inzwischen verstorben gewesen
ist zwei Übernachtungsgäste gehabt hat
also sind die drei da rein wurden von
diesen beiden Herrschaften überrascht
und haben sich dann über sie hergemacht
eigentlich wollten sie nur Geld den
Tresor im Keller stehen aber weil auf
einmal unerwarteter Widerstand dort war
und weil sie auch nicht wussten wie sie
den Tresor öffnen können haben sie
die drei im Schlaf überrascht haben sie
gefoltert wirklich auf brutale Art und
Weise teilweise auch mit dem
Schraubendreher die Wangen durchstochen
und haben dabei die beiden
Übernachtungsgäste getötet die
Hausbesitzerin Luise es haben sie dann
in den Heizungskeller geschafft haben
sie dort gefesselt und die hat drei Tage
über um ihr Überleben gekämpft bis sie
dann gefunden wurde und Gott sei Dank
überlebt hat halten wir das noch mal
fest in der Nacht zum 23 Februar wollen
drei Männer eine alte Frau überfallen
und ausrauben und geraten unter Drogen
in einen Blutrausch
eingeworfen haben die Männer Speed also
Amphetamine das Zeug putscht auf
unterdrückt Hunger Durst und Müdigkeit
und das helle Pulver das meist
geschnupft wird das macht aggressiv das
Trio stimmt die Haustür auf stürmt das
Schlafzimmer von Luise P und fesselt sie
mit einem Abschleppseil Luise Paes Gäste
die 76-Jährige Inge B und der 81 Jahre
alte Johannes s haben sich wegen des
Angst erregenden Lärms in ihrem Zimmer
eingesperrt aber Robert P und seine
Kumpane drücken die Tür mit der Schulter
auf die Täter überwältigen die beiden
und misshandeln sie sofort sie sind
panisch weil der Safe nicht aufgeht und
sie sind offenbar zu jeder Grausamkeit
bereit
in der irrenannahme Johannes s könnte
den Code des Safes kennen foltern sie
ihn mit einem Schraubenzieher sie werfen
ihn und Luise P schließlich in den
Keller Inge B bleibt blutüberströmt im
ersten Stock liegen und stirbt die Täter
um Robert P verlassen das Haus im
idyllischen Höfen in den Morgenstunden
sie nehmen den ganzen Safe mit um ihn
später in Ruhe zu Hause in Polen zu
öffnen Geldscheine Münzen und das Gold
packen sie in einen Wäschekorb ab jetzt
kämpft Luise es im Keller blutend und
stöhnend um ihr Leben
neben ihr liegt ihr toter bekannter
Johannes nach drei Tagen macht ein
Bekannter sich Sorgen weil Luise es
nirgends auftaucht und nicht ans Telefon
geht und ruft die Polizei als die
Beamten eintreffen sind sie vom Zustand
der alten Frau schockiert vor allem aber
muss ich das Bild der Leichen im Keller
bei allen eingebrannt haben Polizisten
Retter Bestatter die Spurensicherung
alle betont später wie erschrecken
grausam die Tat gewesen sein muss
allein Johannes es weist an die 100
Verletzungen auf die Polizei geht
entsprechend mit Hochdruck an die
Ermittlungen
Luise s kann dabei erstmal nicht viel
helfen sobald sie wieder bei Bewusstsein
ist erinnert sie sich nur noch an die
Ankunft ihrer Gäste und dann erst wieder
an den Aufwachraum im Krankenhaus sie
hatte die Freunde vom Bahnhof abgeholt
und war dann mit den beiden gemeinsam
essen gegangen aber allein die Umstände
der Tat geben schnell die Richtung vor
die Tat musste geplant worden sein denn
jemand muss vom safe gewusst haben und
vom Geld darin es ist also ganz
klassisch gute Polizeiarbeit die hier
geleistet wird zum Bild von Luise PES
wenigen Kontakten gehört die ehemalige
Pflegerin aus Polen die wie wir wissen
einen mehrfach vorbestraften Bruder hat
man besorgt sich also dessen DNA-Profil
und schließlich findet sich auf dem
Grundstück ein polnischer
Zigarettenstummel darauf die DNA-Spuren
von Robert P natürlich wird die
Zusammenarbeit mit den polnischen
Kollegen jetzt noch intensiver es folgen
ausgiebige Verhöre und schließlich
weitere Festnahmen das Bild der
grausamen Tat nimmt für die Ermittler
und die Öffentlichkeit Gestalt an
malgosata L hat ihren Bruder Robert auf
den Raub gebracht ihr Sohn Michael kam
mit auf den Beutezug ebenso der bekannte
Jakob geh der Fall gilt als gelöst bis
zum Prozess sind die Angeklagten in der
Münchner JVA Stadelheim untergebracht
das Verfahren wird 16 Monate nach der
Blut hat von Höfen vor dem Landgericht
München eröffnet den Vorsitz hat Richter
Thomas Gott der Blonde Jurist mit dem
verschmitzten Lächeln ist erfahren er
gilt als humorvoll er kann aber auch mal
ein Auge
aber im Umgang mit Robert P Gerät selbst
Bord an seine nervlichen Grenzen die
Anklage wird von Staatsanwältin Ines
Wiesner vertreten sie hat zwar auch
schon einige Verfahren hinter sich ist
aber nicht zu erfahren wie der Richter
die schlanke Frau mit den längeren
blonden Haaren trägt die Einzelheiten
des Verbrechens mit großem Ernst vor als
das Verfahren losgeht nimmt die
überlebende Luise P erstmal noch nicht
teil sie leidet noch immer an den Folgen
der Brutalität vom 23 Februar 2017
der Schwindel ist ganz schlimm ich kann
oft nicht alleine gehen sagt sie ich
habe Angst dass es mich auf den Boden
hinhaut
sie erzählt später übrigens auch dass es
ihr schwer fällt noch in dem Haus zu
wohnen kann ich gut verstehen in dem
Haus in Höfen hat sie mit ihrem Mann
gelebt der dann gestorben ist dann der
Überfall und die Morde das war so übel
da das Haus musste für 16.000 € von
Blutspuren gereinigt werden erst an
einem der späteren Prozess Tage sagt
Luise P aus damit sie die Gegenwart der
Mörder nicht ertragen muss macht sie
ihren Bericht fast zwei Stunden lang von
einem Nebenraum aus und wird per Video
in den Gerichtssaal geschaltet sie
spricht ruhig und bemüht sich Umfassung
sie berichtet von ihren Eindrücken von
Margaret l dass sie ihr Miss traute
obwohl sie sehr fleißig war sogar Wände
habe die Pflegerin bestrichen wie schon
gesagt hat Luise keine Erinnerung an die
Taten macht aber die Beweise wie zum
Beispiel die DNA von der Zigarette die
reichen auch so aus außerdem sagt den
ehemaliger mit Häftling aus der extra
aus einem Bayreuther Gefängnis nach
München gebracht wurde er berichtet von
Gesprächen mit einem der mutmaßlichen
Mörder dieser habe ihm gegenüber in der
Haft geprahlt dass er das männliche
Opfer ungefähr 50 Mal getreten hat alles
sei voller Blut gewesen weil man die Tat
selbst kaum abstreiten kann stellt
Robert P die schrecklichen Ereignisse
als Dummheit unter Drogeneinnahme da bei
der Tat habe er zudem einen
epileptischen Anfall erlitten er habe
niemanden getötet oder könne sich
zumindest nicht daran erinnern was genau
sein Neffe und seinen Komplize Kuba
gemacht haben wisse er nicht das ist
einfach nur ein dreist das Schauspiel
und zwischendurch wird dieser Mörder
auch immer wieder ausfällig einmal
brüllt er den Richter bot an dieser
solle Respekt zeigen
er knallt sein Kopf vor Wut so doll aufs
Pult dass ein Pflaster auf die Wunde
muss die mit Angeklagten verhalten sich
deutlich ruhiger Kuba ist der einzige
der gesteht trotzdem versucht er sich
nur als Handlanger darzustellen Robert
habe dieses und jenes befohlen er habe
angesagt dass er Luise schlagen solle er
habe gesagt wie der Safe ins Auto
getragen werden solle und er Kuba
gehorchte aus Angst wie er jetzt sagt
Herr und immer wieder betonen die drei
Angeklagten dass sie wegen der Drogen
außer Rand und Band gewesen sein und
sich ein wenig erinnerten
das lässt Staatsanwältin Wiesner aber
unbeeindruckt dies hier sei keine
drogentat sondern ein kalt geplanter
Überfall gewesen Robert P habe befohlen
die 76-Jährige Hausbesitzerin
niederzuschlagen er habe befohlen den
self ins Auto zu tragen er hat befohlen
die Kleidung loszuwerten das Geld
aufzuteilen er habe befohlen befohlen
befohlen die Tat sei der Albtraum eines
jeden von uns sagt die Staatsanwältin
die Opfer seien im Schlaf überrascht
überfallen ausgeraubt und getötet worden
danach rafften die Männer laut Wiesner
Goldmünzen Schmuck und Geld in einem
Wäschekorb zusammen und schleppten den
Safe mit nichts am Geschehen sei zu
entschuldigen Wiesner fordert
lebenslange Haftstrafe für alle vier
Angeklagten und für Robert P auch noch
die anschließende Sicherungsverwahrung
er sei gefährlich für die Allgemeinheit
bei der Urteilsverkündung rastet Robert
P fast wieder aus
er springt auf und blickt wild um sich
zwei Gerichtsdiener eilen dazu und
drücken ihn an den Schultern wieder auf
den Stuhl Richter Bott folgt bei den
Urteilen dem plädoy der Anklage nur
malgosata l kommt ohne lebenslang davon
sie muss wegen Raubes acht Jahre hinter
Gittern und damit endet diese Geschichte
eigentlich denn der Doppelmord von Höfen
beschäftigt Reporterin Lena Zander auch
heute noch sie bemüht sich um eine
Genehmigung damit Sie Robert P in der
JVA Straubing besuchen und befragen kann
das ganze fand damals noch unter
corona-bedingungen statt das heißt wir
waren in einem nicht in einem
Besucherraum sondern einem extra Raum
und trennte eine Plexiglasscheibe so wie
es eigentlich ja ein corona-zeiten an
der Supermarktkasse üblich gewesen ist
da Robert P zwar Deutsch spricht und
auch Deutsch versteht aber sich sicherer
an seiner Muttersprache polnisch geführt
hat war eine Übersetzerin mit dabei die
aber nicht physisch anwesend sein konnte
sondern zugeschaltet wurde per Video und
übersetzte ich muss vielleicht vorweg
sagen dass ich ins Gefängnis gefahren
bin
um nicht hauptsächlich über die Tat zu
sprechen weil dieses Verbrechen ist
grausam da gibt es keine Zweifel dran es
sind zwei Menschen ermordet worden dass
es besonders schlimm ich wollte ihm aber
auch nicht die Plattform bieten sich
rein zu waschen oder zu jammern weil es
gibt dann noch einen anderen Aspekt den
ich interessant gefunden habe und zwar
wie lebt man mit dieser Schuld zwei
Menschen auf dem Gewissen zu haben wie
geht man damit um und er ist ein Mensch
so ein Verbrechen wird von Menschen
begangen und natürlich werden diese
Menschen weggesperrt aber sie existieren
so und dazu kommt dass Robert P
gläubiger Katholik ist und sich diese
Taten ja auch schwer mit seinem Glauben
vereinbaren lassen weil er hat gegen
zwei Gebote maßgeblich verstoßen das
fünfte Gebot du sollst nicht töten das
siebte Gebot du sollst nicht stehen also
stand das bei meinem Gespräch im Fokus
das Leben danach die Schuld und sein
Glaube und so macht sich Lena im warmen
Corona Sommer 2020 auf den Weg zu Robert
um endlich ihre Fragen loszuwerden
muss ich sagen ich war überrascht von
der Offenheit von Robert P weil meine
Fragen waren das hat man gemerkt für ihn
auch nicht einfach zu beantworten er
spricht von Albträumen die ihn bis heute
plagen gerade diese Situation die ich
vorhin angesprochen hatte er hat den
älteren Herren ja in den Keller
geschafft die Kellertreppen runter er
nennt es getragen in der Anklageschrift
stand gewaltsam gebracht und
er sagt er wird sich selbst diese Tat
nie verzeihen er betet ist immer noch
tief gläubig er hat sogar damals dem
überlebenden Opfer Luise es einen Brief
geschrieben vor der Gerichtsverhandlung
aus der Untersuchungshaft hinaus da hat
er sich entschuldigt und hat angeboten
falls Sie mal in die Situation käme
Organspenden zu brauchen oder eine
Bluttransfusion würde er da zur
Verfügung stehen man kann sich die
Reaktion von Luise es gut vorstellen die
empört gewesen ist
es war so hat das zumindest gesagt seine
Art sich zu entschuldigen so er glaubt
auch daran dass dass er nach dem Tod in
die Hölle kommt eine gerechte Strafe
bleibt aber die Frage kann man einem
Mörder der seine Taten vor Gericht so
wie im Moment verdrängen wollte
überhaupt glauben ich habe ihm das
geglaubt was vielleicht noch
bemerkenswert ist als er über die Taten
über die Brutalität sprach oder auch als
ich ihn fragte sind sie ein Mörder was
er mit Nein beantwortete obwohl er ja
wirklich verurteilt wurde wegen
Doppelmordes
vielen schwer darüber zu sprechen
vielleicht ist das ich bin kein
Psychologe auch ein Schutzmechanismus
und dass man das ausklammert aber das
was er mir erzählte das habe ich
geglaubt weil ich ein nachdenklichen
Mann erlebt habe mit Schuldgefühlen die
so schwer auf seinen Schultern lasten so
dass ich selbst das spüren konnte mit
einer Reue was die Tat nicht
entschuldigt und nicht erklärt nicht im
Ansatz aber man spürte schon der meint
das was er gerade sagt Ernst er hat ja
auch nichts mehr zu verlieren
mittlerweile ist Robert P nicht mehr in
Straubing ich habe ihn im Juli 2020 in
der JVA in Straubing besucht sein Wunsch
war es nach Polen in einem Gefängnis
über zu siedeln weil dort auf seine
Familie lebt und seine Tochter die er
ganz früh verloren hat auf einem
Friedhof begraben ist und inzwischen ist
es seinen Anwälten auch gelungen dass er
in eine Justizvollzugsanstalt nach Polen
verlegt werden konnte und damit sind wir
am Ende der heutigen Ausgabe
wir haben den Fall des Doppelmordes von
Höfen mit den Aufzeichnungen unserer
Kollegin Lena Zander erzählt sowie mit
sehr guten Schilderungen des Prozesses
aus der Süddeutschen Zeitung dem
Münchner Merkur und der Augsburger
Allgemeinen Skript Stefan netzewandt
Postproduktion weight watch Studios
München bis zum nächsten mal eure Toni
und euer Mirko und falls Ihr Anregungen
Kritik oder weitere fallvorschläge für
uns habt dann schreibt uns gerne eine
E-Mail oder kontaktiert uns bei
Instagram die Links dazu haben wir euch
natürlich wie schon ausgepackt ganz
genau